that we've heard i should say from uh
president biden who has said
that uh he does not want any
inflammation of tensions as far as the
northern ireland peace accord
is concerned and you really need to keep
an eye on that with brexit we've also
heard
from president macron he's saying
nothing is negotiable where does that
lead britain
today i'm fine look um i i was in the
room
unlikely sanandi it was an incredibly
warm bilateral meeting yesterday which
overran because they were
focused on all the common values and
common interests uh from
getting the world vaccinated to dealing
with the challenge of climate change
from the traditional foreign policy
geopolitical concerns from russia to
china
we did touch on the prime minister and
the president did touch on
the northern ireland protocol and we
understand the us interest in it as a
long-standing guarantor of the good
friday agreement
and it was an opportunity for the prime
minister to explain that we want a
flexible
pragmatic approach that deals with the
equities on both sides but for that to
happen the eu must be
less purist more pragmatic and more
flexible in the implementation of it the
ball is very much in the eu's court in
relation to that
frankly we didn't linger on it the
president the prime minister didn't
linger on it there were so many other
things that were discussed
in particular with the first g7 in
almost
two years getting leaders together
dealing with the
uh the forward-looking problems and
challenges of the future from keeping
trade open from building back the
economies greener
stronger uh getting the world vaccinated
on which we've made a very substantial
announcement today our
big cause of getting 40 million more
girls into
12 years of quality education those were
the things that
dominated the conversation incredibly
warm chemistry between the president and
prime minister
the meeting ran over we're excited about
the opportunities this week
okay lots to talk about there but if i
could just continue on with brexit just
for now
what was the tone like when they were
talking about
the northern ireland protocol
that's very respectful i mean the the
nothing like the caricature that we see
in the snippets of the media
or or or all of that but we understand
there's a respectable conversation
the prime minister wanted to raise it
and be very clear on our position
it is the dogmatic purist approach that
the eu has taken
which is the the risk to the good friday
agreement uh that was set up very
articulately by
um david trimble an article for the
times of course the nobel prize winning
architect or one of the architects of
the good friday agreement but we want
this thing to work on all sides we
understand that you use equities but
it's got to work
for all communities in northern ireland
and as i said
this wasn't a large part of the
discussions yesterday
we moved on pretty smartly to all the
other things that we're working together
on the common interest the common values
and as i said a very strong dynamic
between the president the prime minister
president macron is arriving in town
later on today though he's saying that
nothing is negotiable as far as brexit
is concerned
we can't extend past the end of june we
have to have an agreement
by then on what's happening with this
border in the irish sea
or can we can we extend past uh the end
of june
i think the ball is very much in the
eu's court we understand what uh
the french have said and that ought to
focus minds in the commission in
brussels on taking a more
pragmatic flexible approach the northern
ireland protocol was always a compromise
reflecting different interests
reflecting all sides and all communities
in northern ireland as well as the eu
zone equities and it needs to be
implemented in a way
which reflects and delivers for all
sides um and that's the problem at the
moment that the eu has taken
uh an overly purist approach uh but we
want it to work for all sides but
but but the change must come from the
commission side and the way they're
approaching this and we
we we're not negotiating or haggling the
integrity of the united kingdom whether
it's territorial
constitutional or indeed the economic
integrity of the uk it's not that it's
not up on the table for
for negotiating and before i move on
final question on that if i can press
you can
britain extend past the end of june on
trying to come up with a deal to sort
out what's happening in northern ireland
we take a pragmatic approach to all of
these things but i said the
the bottom line for us is that the
threat and the risk to the good friday
agreement comes from the approach
uh that the eu is taking a particularly
purist approach
and uh the principle of the good friday
agreement there's no change
without the consent of the people is
something that that is the the eu and
the northern ireland protocol
in the specific way that it's being
approached and implementing is putting
at risk
but we're pragmatic we've there's a
strong well of good will on the uk side
we've put forward proposals it's up to
the eu now to come forward with a
a way that delivers win-win rather than
the divisive approach we've seen
recently
talk to me about vaccines 100 million is
what we are going to
donate we heard from gordon brown on the
program earlier in the week saying
no one's safe until everyone is safe is
100 million enough or is it just a drop
in the bucket
so let's just take a half step back
remember at the start of this we put the
uk
through taxpayers money put 90 million
pounds into developing the astrazeneca
vaccine not only have we had a very
successful roller at home
but 95 percent of the kovacs vaccines
the global mechanism to get vaccines
to the poorest and most vulnerable
countries around the world 95
of those have come from astrazeneca so
very much part of britain's push and
internationalist approach
on top of that we secured a billion
doses by funding kovacs that
international mechanism now what we're
saying is we're far
far enough forward with our domestic
rollout that we can now
make the pledge to deliver uh 100
million
from our excess vaccine the surplus from
our vaccine
roll out at home to vaccinate the
world's poorest
the international community by the
middle part
of next year we're going to do 5 million
in the coming
weeks and months we will do 25 million
more of those doses by the end of this
calendar year 100 million by the mid
part
of next year and just to give you the
strategic significance kay
uh the point is if we went on the
current trajectory the
the world would be vaccinated by the end
of 2024.
what we're doing is uh joining up with
the us and the other g7 members
leading by example with our hundred
millions but getting the aim is to get
the world vaccinated by
the end of 2022 if we can do that we'll
be making a real
uh step forward in dealing with the
pandemic globally which is important
because we know no one's safe
until everyone's safe
quite right and you say that kovacs is
for the world's poorest and most
vulnerable but then we've we learned
that
canada which is one of the g7 countries
actually took two million
vaccines from kovacs um what's your
thought on that
we work very closely with our canadian
colleagues i think they're one of
uh the the leading internationalist
countries in the world we have great
rapport with them and the prime minister
looks forward to seeing
prime minister trudeau but one of the
advantages of what we've done today is
we've not just launched
uh a uk initiative what we're doing is
using our convening power to get the g7
countries to say okay
we've produced uh we're going to provide
this extra 100 million doses
what can we do together to make sure we
get the world vaccinated by the end of
2022
that's the prime minister's approach
that's what global britain's a force for
good is all about
and that's what we hope the g7 will
achieve and of course i'm sure
canada will be an essential part of that
yeah has the uk taking any vaccines from
kovacs
we i mean not that i'm aware of but as i
said before
95 of the kovacs distributed vaccines
have come from a z which we've
uh funded with the startup cost the 90
million
that was of course a vaccine that has
been made at cost so no profit
and distributed uh to the world we
secured a billion
doses we paid for a billion doses just
over uh half a billion pounds
to provide that extra funding and now
we're uh
uh providing um a hundred million extra
doses from the surplus from our domestic
rollout so that
anyone can question that we are leading
internationally by example
are you comfortable reducing the uk's uh
the uk's commitment to overseas aid
look i recognize that as a temporary
matter of
financial emergency because of a hit
that kovid had
on our economy and our public finances
that we had to look at this in the round
and the savings that we've
been forced to make would not just come
from the domestic programs that we've
got but the international ones
so it's not something it's something we
did in sorrow not with any relish we'll
get back to 0.7
as soon as we can but just to make the
point we're still putting in 10
billion pounds of aid this year will be
the third biggest
um g7 donor by a proportion of gross
national income we're still in bilateral
terms the third biggest
uh donor to humanitarian causes around
the world
so i i i don't think we need to be
defensive about this the united kingdom
is still at point five percent is a
major force for good in the world and
that includes
our own spend from secretary there are
suggestions i read in the newspapers
this morning that there could well be a
travel
corridor for want of a better way of
putting it between the uk
and the us how much credence should we
be giving to that given that you were in
the room yesterday when the two leaders
were speaking
well i think we're in a position to make
a formal announcement about it but of
course um
we're looking at that uh issue with the
us and with others
and as soon as we can we want to open up
but as you know okay you've heard
minister say it before
we're in this race at the moment between
getting everyone second dose vaccinated
in the uk
and making sure that the variants don't
spread
and that's the number one priority so we
can't open up
um as much as we'd like until we've got
the
uh the the clarity and the evidence to
show that we've won that race we'll know
more of course next week
so we shouldn't be too excited about
suggestions that there's a travel
corridor between the us and the uk
as yet we all want to do it it was
something that was discussed yesterday
and we've got an idea about how to take
it forward but it's not something we'll
be announcing imminently
um okay just before i let you go i
believe there's a barbecue on the beach
tomorrow toasting marshmallows and the
like certainly not the weather for it um
today what do you want people what do
you want the leaders of the g7 to take
away
from their experience in cornwall
cornwall is beautiful this is the first
um net zero g7 summit so we're
not just talking the talk but we're
walking the walk but i think the most
important thing
is that countries can come together to
tackle the world's problems whether it's
climate change whether it's dealing with
this awful pandemic
whether it's standing up for our values
the values that we hold dear
human rights open trade and also
broadening the group of like-minded
countries that will stand up for those
values
the prime minister invited uh prime
minister modi so india south korea
australia we've got the south africans
as well and actually we need to broaden
the caucus the
the the range of countries willing to
stand up for the traditional atlantic
charter values
and i think the choice of guests at this
g7 summit as well as the
the g7 leaders themselves is very
important
final thought before i let you go i hear
the prime minister went for a swim in on
in the sea yesterday you tempted at all
in your speedos today
uh it's too cold for me uh but you know
he's very brave
and hardy um and uh but it's a bit too
nippy for me i'm afraid okay
you've got a busy few days ahead of you
we very much appreciate
you taking the time to join us here on
sky news thank you so much thanks a lot
good to talk to you guys